joe budden was a little critical of this
record he's a fan of you guys obviously
but uh was that just coming with having
maul in the video well definitely maul
played a part in that i think we knew
once maul was in the video
i mean it's crazy because um
i wasn't thinking about it at all and
then i it hit me as like oh you know
what joe my jill's going to probably
have something to say because he said
you guys talk right
we you know we dm and here and there
he's an r b fan like he talks about r b
a lot yeah he he you know he's he's good
for
saying a lot of
real things but he's also good for just
kind of just saying things sometimes so
it is what it is you know he's
he i think he said we dropped an album
in 2016 then another one in 2019 and so
we don't drop enough for him and i was
like that is not our album
that's not accurate at all but shout out
to joe you know whatever it is what it
is she just can't he's just not the
division wikipedia he thinks he is yeah
and sometimes he's just
wrong on records